Desde que estalló la guerra en Ucrania los
analistas se han vuelto completamente locos
intentando prever qué puede pasar una vez
que se termine el conflicto…Si es que eso
ocurre algún día.
Y, ojo, porque hay quienes incluso han proyectado
que podría estar en juego la mismísima desintegración
de Rusia como país unificado.
Vale, puede que muchas de estas teorías sean
pura propaganda, estimaciones al límite o,
dadas las circunstancias, atiendan a ciertos
intereses, pero no dejan de ser curiosas y
desde luego lo que aquí en VisualPolitik
más nos importa es que muchos de sus argumentos…
Son ciertos.
Pues bien, una de estas teorías nos ha llamado
mucho la atención porque se pregunta algo
que la mayoría quizás no nos habríamos
planteado jamás:
¿Hasta qué punto puede contribuir el yihadismo
a la desintegración de Rusia?
Boom.
Seguro que justo ahora os estaréis preguntando,
¿pero, Alberto, qué demonios tiene que ver
el yihadismo con Rusia?
¿Hay acaso tantos musulmanes en la Federación?
Pues, sí, lo cierto es que sí.
Aproximadamente el 15% de toda la población
rusa es musulmana y se prevé que esta cifra
pueda superar el 20% para el año 2030.
Y, llamadme loco, pero hablamos de una población
musulmana que en pocos años superará ampliamente
los 25 millones de habitantes, lo que viene
a ser el doble de la población que tiene
Moscú.
Así que diría que este sí que es un tema
relevante.
¿No os parece?
Y, no solo eso, es que además el islam es
la religión mayoritaria en varias regiones
de Rusia, fijaos en este mapa:
Como podéis ver, son 7 los territorios con
mayoría musulmana en Rusia:
las 5 repúblicas autónomas del Cáucaso
Norte, así como Tartaristán y Bashkortostán
en la región del Volga-Ural.
Y aunque en Rusia como tal no hay una religión
oficial - Supuestamente se constituye como
un Estado laico - a la hora de la verdad la
religión atraviesa todo el campo de la política
nacional.
Y si no, que se lo digan al Patriarca Kirill.
N1(El líder de la Iglesia Ortodoxa dice que
los soldados rusos que mueran en Ucrania quedarán
limpios de pecado.
Reuters.)
(En cualquier caso lo cierto es que en la
mayor del país el Cristianismo ortodoxo es
la religión mayoritaria…
Cerca del 80% de los rusos se declaran como
tal…
Aunque lo cierto es que son muy poco prácticamente…
Algunos datos apuntan a que apenas el 4% asisten
regularmente a oficios religiosos.
Claro que el peso de la Iglesia Ortodoxa ha
crecido en los últimos años gracias precisamente
a Putin.)
C1("Estamos simplemente al comienzo del renacimiento
espiritual de nuestro pueblo" Patriarca Kirill)
Sea como sea, pese a ello en los 7 territorios
donde el islam es mayoritario, incluso la
Sharía está a la orden del día, especialmente
en las repúblicas del Cáucaso Norte:
¿Queréis un ejemplo?
Pues digamos que mas vale que en Chechenia
no te vean demasiado cariñoso con alguien
de tu mismo sexo porque….
o te pegan una paliza hasta matarte o te mandan
directamente a un campo de concentración.
Sí, así se las gastan en esta zona del mundo.
En este territorio muchas mezquitas se han
dedicado a radicalizar a todo los feligreses
que podían para alimentar el yihadismo en
Chechenia, el Daguestán, Ingushetia y en
general en todas las regiones musulmanas de
Rusia.
Por tanto, sabiendo todo esto, la pregunta
es:
¿Hasta qué punto puede el yihadismo convertirse
en un verdadero problema para Moscú?
¿Cómo ha sido hasta ahora el movimiento
de estos grupos en Rusia?
¿Hasta qué punto hablamos de un choque inminente
que puede alimentar incluso deseos secesionistas?
En este vídeo vamos a responder a todas estas
preguntas, pero antes vamos a ver un poco
de historia.
T1(EL EMIRATO DEL CÁUCASO)
Estoy seguro que más o menos todos sabemos
la historia del Estado Islámico.
Durante años los medios no pararon de bombardearnos
con noticias de sus avances en Siria y en
Irak.
Pero seguro, seguro que seréis muy pocos
los que sepáis que Rusia tuvo que hacer frente,
en su propio territorio, a un movimiento yihadista
parecido al del Estado Islámico.
Sí, sí, habéis escuchado bien.
Hablamos del Emirato del Cáucaso.
Vale, es verdad que no fue tan grande ni tuvo
tanto impacto en Rusia como el Estado Islámico
en Oriente Medio, pero aún así resultó
un auténtico quebradero de cabeza para Putin.
Pensad que si el Emirato se hubiera convertido
en un Estado, hubiera sido más grande en
territorio y población que Georgia, Armenia
y Azerbaiyán.
Pero, claro, la pregunta es, ¿tan importante
es el islam en Rusia como para que unos cuantos
radicales llegaran a crear su propio Emirato?
Pues digamos que sí.
Y Desde luego, es más importante de lo que
podríais llegar a pensar.
(El islam llegó al territorio de la actual
Rusia en el siglo VII, extendiéndose justamente
por el Cáucaso.
Desde entonces, ya fuera en Daguestán, Ingusetia
o Chechenia, el islam comenzó a coger fuerza
hasta convertirse en la religión mayoritaria
de toda la región caucásica.
Claro que no fue un proceso limpio sino que
estuvo acompañado de varias campañas de
represión contra la población musulmana
del Cáucaso, y también contra los tártaros
musulmanes del Volga-Ural.
Desde Iván el Terrible en el siglo XVI hasta
la Unión Soviética, el islam estuvo duramente
reprimido por largos periodos de tiempo en
lo que hoy comprende la madre Rusia.
Sin embargo, con la caída de la Unión Soviética,
volvió la apertura religiosa y, con ello,
el resurgir de la fe musulmana en el país.
Y no solo eso, también comenzaron a crearse
instituciones musulmanas como la Unión de
Musulmanes de Rusia, y numerosas madrassas
y universidades islámicas como la Universidad
Islámica de Daguestán.
De hecho, el Islam es tan importante que incluso
está reconocido en la Constitución Federal
de Rusia como una de las cuatro religiones
tradicionales del país.
Y como decíamos antes es la fe elegida por
el 10% de toda la población del país, es
decir, unos 15 millones de personas.
Claro que hablamos de una población relativamente
más joven y con más hijos, motivo por el
cual su peso no deja de crecer.)
Y, vale, es cierto que el hecho de que haya
una población musulmana razonablemente grande
en un país no significa que tengan que existir,
sí o sí, problemas con facciones radicales.
Pero, queridos amigos, amigas, puede no ocurrir,
pero este sí ha sido el caso de Rusia.
De hecho, el Emirato del Cáucaso no es más
que la herencia de los enfrentamientos y las
dos guerras sangrientas entre Rusia y Chechenia
que se libraron entre principios de los años
90 y bien entrado el siglo XXI.
Y es que, como seguramente muchos sepáis,
la tensión entre Rusia y Chechenia ha sido
tradicionalmente muy alta.
Ya en la Rusia zarista, los chechenos se levantaron
en armas contra los rusos para intentar conseguir
su independencia.
Y, durante la época soviética Chechenia
fue unida a Ingushetia para formar una sola
república.
De hecho, se llevaban tan mal con Rusia que
lucharon junto a los nazis.
Y al fina l, cuando la Unión Soviética cayó,
Chechenia se autodeclaró independiente en
1991.
Pero no fue hasta 1994 cuando Moscú reaccionó
con toda su fuerza y, desde entonces hasta
2002, las operaciones militares se mantuvieron
en Chechenia poniendo oficialmente fin al
conflicto…Aunque luego la insurgencia se
extendió todavía unos cuantos años más.
Sea como sea, esto supuso todo un espaldarazo
para el entonces nuevo líder ruso.
Digamos que con las tropas ya apostadas en
Chechenia mostrando su poderío, Putin empezó
a respirar con tranquilidad.
Los ataques terroristas de los separatistas
chechenos comenzaron a dejar de producirse
bajo la atenta mirada del padre de nuestro
viejo conocido, Ramzan Kadyrov.
Pero, lo que no sabía Putin era que, aunque
cerró la puerta del separatismo checheno,
automáticamente se abrió una amplia ventana
al terrorismo yihadista.
Y esa ventana dio lugar a que, en 2007, el
líder separatista checheno, [Dokú Umárov]
Dokka Umarov, creara el Emirato del Cáucaso
y comenzara la yihad contra Rusia.
Pero, ¿qué fue exactamente el Emirato del
Cáucaso?
Pues es básicamente el proyecto de un nuevo
Estado independiente, regido por la Sharía
y que ocuparía todo el Cáucaso Norte.
Es decir, no solo las repúblicas autónomas
de la región como Chechenia, Daguestán e
Ingushetia, sino todo el territorio que va
desde el Daguestán hasta el propio mar de
Azov.
Y, seguro, seguro que muchos estáis pensando
que Chechenia era la parte más importante
de este nuevo Emirato, ¿verdad?
Pues…
ERROR.
Daguestán se llevó la palma.
Los yihadistas de Chechenia no se contentaron
con quedarse en la tierra de Kadyrov, sino
que empezaron a expandirse por la región.
De hecho, para que os hagáis una idea, el
Emir que sucedió a Umarov fue un daguestano.
Luego otra prueba de que Daguestán se terminó
convirtiendo en el epicentro del yihadismo
en la región es que esta fue, precisamente,
la región con más víctimas y heridos por
atentados terroristas de corte yihadista.
Chechenia ocupó, por tanto, un segundo escalón.
Pero, ¿quiénes son estos grupos que impulsaron
el Emirato del Cáucaso?
¿Qué peso real tienen en la región?
¿Qué peligro suponen?
¿Son todos los musulmanes partidarios de
esta línea de acción contra Moscú?
Pues bien, veámoslo.
T2(SUFISMO VS.
SALAFISMO)
De verdad que en VisualPolitik sabemos perfectamente
que eso de explicar las diferencias entre
distintas ramas dentro de una misma religión
no es una tarea nada fácil.
Y, por supuesto, el islam no es una excepción,
por eso para comprender el problema del yihadismo
hay que conocer las principales diferencias.
EVamos a hacerlo sencillo, ya lo hemos visto
en alguna que otra ocasión.
El islam está dividido fundamentalmente en
dos grandes familias: los sunitas y los chiitas.
Esta división se remonta a poco después
de la muerte de Mahoma en el 632 después
de Cristo.
Desde entonces, los musulmanes quedaron divididos
entre los que creían que los califas debían
ser los sucesores del profeta, empezando por
el primo y yerno de Mahoma, Alí Ibn Abi Tálib.
Estos eran y son los chiitas; que por su carácter
hereditario mantienen una jerarquía liderada
por los ayatolás mucho más centralizada
e influyente.
Y luego por otro lado, están los musulmanes
que no creían que Mahoma hubiera dejado herederos
religiosos directos y que por tanto los líderes
espirituales tenían que ser escogidos por
la comunidad.
Estos fueron los sunitas, cuya organización
se basa en una enorme descentralización.
Pues bien, como en casi todo el mundo, en
Rusia los sunitas también son mayoría.
Pero, ojo, porque dentro del sunismo también
hay otras divisiones, y la que más nos interesa
es la que existe en el Cáucaso Norte entre
sufistas y salafistas.
Y ya se lo que estaréis pensando: si son
de la misma rama musulmana, no tendrán muchas
diferencias, ¿no?
Pues…
Nada más lejos de la realidad.
(Podríamos decir que, en general, el sufismo
es una rama minoritaria en el mundo musulmán.
Su énfasis, a diferencia de la mayoría sunita,
no está en la pureza de los ritos religiosos,
sino sobre todo en la vida espiritual.
Es decir, buscan una relación más mística
con Alá desde un plano muy individual, respetando
siempre, eso sí, los pilares básicos del
islam.
El salafismo, por otra parte, es mucho, muchísimo
más fundamentalista.
C2(“El salafismo tradicionalista, además
de en la pureza de la doctrina, se concentra
en la predicación, con vistas a reforzar
la fe, preservar la cohesión de la comunidad
y defender el orden moral islámico, un discurso
que coincide con (…) la ruptura con los
musulmanes más tibios”
Federico Aznar Fernández-Montesinos (2014)
Y es que no se diferencian únicamente en
cuanto a su visión más o menos individualista
o colectivista: por ejemplo, los salafistas
rechazan la innovación en el islam porque
la consideran una desviación del camino marcado
por Alá.
Su objetivo es restaurar la práctica original
del Islan rechazando la influencia de la cultura
y las tradiciones locales.
Los sufíes, en cambio, toleran y promueven
cierta innovación.
Incluso tienen sus propios santos, algo que
los salafistas rechazan totalmente.
Pero la diferencia más importante sigue siendo
sus posturas frente a la yihad, ya que los
salafistas la defienden en gran medida, mientras
que los sufíes son mucho más moderados.)
Como podéis ver, no podemos decir ni mucho
menos que el sufismo y el salafismo sean gemelos.
Por eso, no resulta extraño que, allí donde
se encuentran ambos a la vez, suela aparecer
la tensión y el conflicto entre ambas facciones.
Que es precisamente el caso del Cáucaso Norte.
Aquí el sufismo está bien establecido y
es la rama del islam que lógicamente tiene
el apoyo de Moscú.
Sin embargo, pese a ello, la realidad es que
el salafismo ha cogido fuerza desde las guerras
en Chechenia y según algunas estimaciones
hasta 700.000 musulmanes podrían haberlo
adoptado en Rusia.
Sea como sea, el salafismo actual comenzó
su expansión a nivel global en los años
70 gracias en gran medida al dinero de Arabia
Saudí, que se dedicó a construir mezquitas
salafistas por todo el mundo.
Y, claro, como era de esperar, en muchas de
estas mezquitas no solo se hacían meros oficios
inocentes, sino que en sí mismo también
servían como centros de radicalización.
Y, desde luego, como todos podemos imaginarnos,
cuanto peor están las circunstancias en un
lugar, más fácil resulta radicalizar la
fe.
Por eso el salafismo ha sido tan popular en
el Cáucaso Norte, porque sus repúblicas
autónomas tienen los peores datos económicos
de Rusia: Para que os hagáis una idea, Ingushetia
tiene el desempleo más alto con un 30%, la
pobreza en Karachay-Cherkessia alcanza el
25%...
Y de hecho, echad un vistazo a esta tabla.
Como podéis ver, las 5 repúblicas autónomas
del Cáucaso ruso se encuentran entre las
10 regiones más pobres del país.
Claro que esta lucha entre sufismo y salafismo
no es exclusiva del Cáucaso.
Encontramos algo muy parecido en África.
Por ejemplo, en Ghana, entre el año 2000
y el 2010, las ONGs salafistas del país construyeron
91 mezquitas y 89 colegios.
Y en todo el continente africano, la Agencia
Kuwaití de Musulmanes de África ha llegado
a cifrar en 6.000 las mezquitas y 800 los
centros educativos que los salafistas han
construido en los últimos 35 años.
Por lo tanto, hablamos de una lucha entre
el sufismo y el salafismo de carácter global.
En este caso, en Rusia, Moscú se alineó
con el sufismo para pararle los pies al salafismo
yihadista.
Y, a decir verdad, han tenido bastante éxito….
Al menos hasta ahora.
Atentos:
T3(EL ANTÍDOTO RUSO AL SALAFISMO)
Como ya hemos visto, tras la caída de la
Unión Soviética, la religión volvió a
formar parte de nuevo de la sociedad rusa.
Claro que no todas las religiones han sido
tratadas igual.
De hecho, el Cristianismo ortodoxo se ha beneficiado
y mucho de esta nueva tolerancia con la religión.
Mientras el resto de Europa iba separando
cada vez más las relaciones entre el Estado
y la religión, Rusia ha financiado generosamente
a la Iglesia ortodoxa, le ha dado privilegios
de todo tipo, le ha permitido enseñar su
religión en los colegios, influir decisivamente
en las leyes y, por supuesto, construir todas
las iglesias que quieran.
Lo que supone un claro punto de tensión con
la comunidad musulmana del país.
Fijaos.
N2(“Los musulmanes de Moscú no encuentran
sitio en la mezquita”.
BBCPor ejemplo, mientras en Moscú hay 600
iglesias ortodoxas públicas, apenas hay un
puñado de mezquitas públicas, de libre acceso,
para entre dos y cuatro millones de musulmanes
que se calcula que hay en Moscú.
Lógicamente, con todos estos privilegios,
el caldo de cultivo p ara el radicalismo está
más que servido.
Pero Putin, lo sabe,y por eso también ha
procurado mantener buenas relaciones con los
musulmanes rusos.
Digamos que apoyar al islam institucionalizado,
sobre todo al de corte sufí en el Cáucaso,
es la forma con la que quiere luchar contra
el salafismo yihadista.
(Desde Moscú se apoya al islam regido por
tres instituciones: el Consejo Ruso de los
Muftis, la Junta Central de Clérigos Musulmanes
y el Centro de Coordinación de los Musulmanes
del Cáucaso Norte.
Si las organizaciones musulmanas del país
y de las repúblicas autónomas del Cáucaso
quieren recibir financiación pública de
estas instituciones, ser salafistas no les
servirá de nada.
Además, Moscú también se ha centrado en
extender la educación del islam sufí, tanto
en escuelas como en centros de reeducación
de excombatientes yihadistas, lo cual es especialmente
importante por el atractivo que el salafismo
en las generaciones más jóvenes.
)
Sin embargo, lo que más mella ha conseguido
hacer en el salafismo del Cáucaso ha sido
la acción directa, es decir, la acción militar.
eDespués de aprobar una serie de leyes a
finales de los años 90 y principios del nuevo
siglo sobre las asociaciones religiosas y
la lucha contra las actividades terroristas,
Moscú se puso manos a la obra.
Tanto con sus efectivos militares, que al
menos hasta el comienzo de la guerra en Ucrania
se cifraban en unos 80.000 soldados desplegados
en la región, como con los ejércitos de
los hombres fuertes de Putin, como es, por
ejemplo, el caso del propio Kadyrov.
De esta forma, el yihadismo ha ido perdiendo
fuerza.
De hecho, la presión y los acuerdos de Moscú
con muchos gerifaltes locales hicieron que
la propia población del Cáucaso estuviera
comprometida en la lucha contra el yihadismo.
Y, si no me creéis, preguntadle a estas mujeres
chechenas:
N3(“Engañando al mal: Mujeres chechenas
engañan al ISIS haciéndose pasar por novias
de terroristas” Fox News)
Vale, no es la acción más heroica del mundo,
pero aquí lo que cuenta es quitarle dinero
a los yihadistas, así que chapó por ellas.
Y, a decir verdad, es la falta de dinero lo
que también ha hecho que haya perdido fuelle
el yihadismo ruso.
Desde la aparición del Estado Islámico en
Siria e Irak, la mayor parte del dinero de
la yihad global fue a parar allí, y el Emirato
del Cáucaso se quedó tanto sin dinero como
sin combatientes.
Así que estando así las cosas, al final
el Emirato del Cáucaso, el mayor exponente
de las aspiraciones salafistas yihadistas
en Rusia, desapareció en 2016.
Pero, cuidado, porque esto no significa que
el salafismo como tal haya desaparecido.
Es más, sigue siendo tremendamente popular
entre la juventud caucásica, porque les ofrece
una salida en un territorio dónde las oportunidades
brillan por su ausencia.
Y no solamente para los caucásicos, en Tartaristán,
otra república autónoma dentro de Rusia
en la zona del Volga-Ural, también hubo grupos
yihadistas.
Alguno de ellos han protagonizado noticias
como esta:
N4(“Líderes musulmanes rusos atacados en
Tartaristán” AlJazeera)
Vale, no es la acción más heroica del mundo,
pero aquí lo que cuenta es quitarle dinero
a los yihadistas, así que chapó por ellas.
Y, a decir verdad, es la falta de dinero lo
que también ha hecho que haya perdido fuelle
el yihadismo ruso.
Desde la aparición del Estado Islámico en
Siria e Irak, la mayor parte del dinero de
la yihad global fue a parar allí, y el Emirato
del Cáucaso se quedó tanto sin dinero como
sin combatientes.
Así que estando así las cosas, al final
el Emirato del Cáucaso, el mayor exponente
de las aspiraciones salafistas yihadistas
en Rusia, desapareció en 2016.
Pero, cuidado, porque esto no significa que
el salafismo como tal haya desaparecido.
Es más, sigue siendo tremendamente popular
entre la juventud caucásica, porque les ofrece
una salida en un territorio dónde las oportunidades
brillan por su ausencia.
Y no solamente para los caucásicos, en Tartaristán,
otra república autónoma dentro de Rusia
en la zona del Volga-Ural, también hubo grupos
yihadistas.
Alguno de ellos han protagonizado noticias
como esta:
N4(“Líderes musulmanes rusos atacados en
Tartaristán” AlJazeera)
Vale, no es la acción más heroica del mundo,
pero aquí lo que cuenta es quitarle dinero
a los yihadistas, así que chapó por ellas.
Y, a decir verdad, es la falta de dinero lo
que también ha hecho que haya perdido fuelle
el yihadismo ruso.
Desde la aparición del Estado Islámico en
Siria e Irak, la mayor parte del dinero de
la yihad global fue a parar allí, y el Emirato
del Cáucaso se quedó tanto sin dinero como
sin combatientes.
Así que estando así las cosas, al final
el Emirato del Cáucaso, el mayor exponente
de las aspiraciones salafistas yihadistas
en Rusia, desapareció en 2016.
Pero, cuidado, porque esto no significa que
el salafismo como tal haya desaparecido.
Es más, sigue siendo tremendamente popular
entre la juventud caucásica, porque les ofrece
una salida en un territorio dónde las oportunidades
brillan por su ausencia.
Y no solamente para los caucásicos, en Tartaristán,
otra república autónoma dentro de Rusia
en la zona del Volga-Ural, también hubo grupos
yihadistas.
Alguno de ellos han protagonizado noticias
como esta:
N4(“Líderes musulmanes rusos atacados en
Tartaristán” AlJazeera)
En general, hasta ahora, Rusia ha sabido contener
la oleada de terrorismo yihadista que asoló
el país y al Cáucaso Norte en años anteriores.
Ese proyecto separatista yihadista que fue
el Emirato del Cáucaso fracasó ante la mano
dura de Putin y sus hombres fieles.
Por eso, puede que las teorías que han surgido
a raíz de la guerra en Ucrania sobre las
presiones secesionistas de la Rusia islámica
pueden ser exageradas.
Sin embargo, esperad un momento.
Si las cosas en Rusia se siguen poniendo peor,
con las sanciones impactando en la economía
y un flujo constante de jóvenes muriendo
en el frente, eso podría convertirse en el
punto de inflexión perfecto para que volviera
no sólo a cobrar fuerza el salafismo sino,
también, los deseos secesionistas de la Rusia
musulmana.
Y, ojo, porque la historia nos dice que no
resulta tan fácil mantener territorios ampliamente
islámicos bajo el control de un Estado que
cada vez está más ligado a otra religión.
En este caso, el cristianismo ortodoxo.
Así que este es, queridos amigos, amigas,
uno de los puntos débiles a los que Rusia
podría tener que enfrentarse durante los
próximos años o, incluso décadas.
Una población pobre y joven de más de 25
millones de musulmanes con una identidad cultural
y religiosa tan diferente a la de Moscú podría
terminar convirtiéndose en toda una bomba
de relojería.
Pero dicho esto, ahora la pregunta es para
todos vosotros: ¿Creéis que la estrategia
de Rusia para frenar el yihadismo y el salafismo
puede replicarse en todo el mundo?
¿Es el yihadismo en Rusia un gigante dormido
que puede despertar en cualquier momento y
desatar el caos en la madre Rusia?
¿Podría llegar a provocar el surgimiento
de movimientos separatistas en un futuro próximo?
Podéis dejarnos vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios.
Como siempre, no olvidéis que aquí en VisualPolitik
sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así
que suscribíos a este canal y dadle a la
campanita para no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo.
Un saludo y hasta pronto.